domestic
policy is very much caught up in a web
of laws and domestic uh political
interests
um every major
interest in the united states
has a way to influence the way
congress works the timber industry or
the gas industry or
the chemical industry or the credit card
industry or the financial industry
they all have decisive influence over
certain members of congress
which they buy through the political
system in the united states of
what's essentially legalized bribery if
as you see it from any other country
um and the
clash of so many special interests in
their own profit makes progress through
course
anything very difficult but in old
affairs
you can proceed without conventional
approval
so for example just to pick one out of
the air
um what should be the united states
policy toward
ukraine so ukraine is bordering
right on russia uh
it has been the united states project
to promote anti-russian feeling
in ukraine and to try to do everything
we can
to uh weaken any efforts
to build stronger ties between russia
and ukraine we want ukraine
to be an ally of the west and to help us
weaken russia
we would like to send heavy military
equipment into ukraine
we would love to carry out military
maneuvers
on the soil of ukraine we would like to
encourage
ukrainian politicians to be defiant of
russia
now you might pull back and ask yourself
why would we want to do that why would
we want to provoke russia by
fomenting trouble in the country on
russia's border
no country can tolerate
upheaval and interference by a major
global rival in a country right on its
border
we wouldn't like china to open up a
military base in tijuana
or we wouldn't be appreciate large-scale
russian military maneuvers in quebec
on the shores of the great lakes uh but
yet
we are constantly poking our stick in
russia's
eye by carrying out military maneuvers
in the baltics in some cases
right on the border with russia um
carl's also doing the same thing with
aggressive military patrolling in the
south china sea
a president could decide i don't do that
anymore
we're not going to have a policy of
trying to
provoke trouble for russia
and china by fomenting upheaval on their
borders we're not going to do that
anymore
so he could do that just on his own he
could decide for example we're not
selling
weaponry uh you current
uh government that want to use up and
read to provoke russia
anymore if russia
for example would like to build
complete its gas pipeline to germany
we're not going to object to that
anymore the trump administration is very
upset
about this we would say to ourselves
russia and germany made an
accountability gas pipeline
that's up to them we're not going to
interfere
that would be a big change in american
policy and that's a change
that the united states could make with
the uh
with a stroke of a pen how about our
policy toward venezuela
we are intensely working to overthrow
the government of venezuela in a variety
of different ways
a new president could say i don't think
biden will
oh we don't care about overthrowing the
government of venezuela anymore we're
just going to leave it up to the
venezuelans that could be
something that you don't need any
congressional approval to do
and that goes for american policy
towards countries in most of the world
we could decide we want a whole
different policy toward china
a different policy toward russia and you
don't need to consult congress for that
so that's why i say a new
incoming president has much more leeway
in dealing with changes in foreign
policy than in trying to change domestic
policy
do you think presidents
necessarily know a lot about foreign
policy like
do you think they they have a a
comprehensive understanding like
someone like you like someone like you
does of
things that are going on in russia china
venezuela
and the cause and effect of all of it or
do they just have war generals around
them telling them what to do you have to
do this
i think joe biden believes he knows a
lot about world affairs
he has served for years and years on the
senate foreign relations committee ins
including extended periods as chairman
of the senate foreign relations
committee he's been traveling all over
the world he has met many world leaders
uh so to a certain degree he's right in
thinking that he knows a lot about the
world
on the other hand he's so much a product
of the republican democrat
established think tank media
mindset in washington that he's never
pulled back from dealing with individual
crises to ask themselves a larger
question about
what should the united states be doing
in the world why do we
insist on being the dominant power in
south america the dominant power in
africa that we should decide what
happens in the caucuses
that we should shape events in the south
china sea how long can we continue to do
this in the modern
particularly given all the needs at home
uh so i i don't think
that he himself has pulled back enough
to ask himself those larger questions
a number of americans who are highly
qualified have done that
and would be great members of a national
security team
for the biden administration but i don't
expect that to happen
ask yourself as you see the secretary of
state and secretary of defense
and their deputies and the people on the
national security council selected
how many of those people said it was a
bad idea to get involved in syria
we shouldn't have bombed libya we never
should have invaded iraq
go back and find the people who said
that and you won't find any of them
being rewarded with posts in the new
administration in fact
having been right about the disastrous
consequences of those interventions
effectively
disqualifies you from service in a
future administration whereas having
been wrong
and supporting those interventions that
worked out so disastrously
qualifies you imminently
and why is that why why do you think
it's like that
it has to do with our national
consciousness and our national
self-image
we are a country that always thinks of
ourselves as the best the biggest the
strongest
we've convinced ourselves that it's not
selfish for us to want to dominate the
world
it's good for the world we sacrifice
to help the rest of the world and
sometimes the world doesn't quite
appreciate it but without
us there would be chaos we feed
ourselves
this narrative that we are as madeleine
albright put it the indispensable nation
because
what does she say we we stand taller and
we see further than other nations
it's very difficult for us to convince
ourselves that actually we may not have
the key
to uh prosperity and security
for all people all over the world that
maybe other people want to go in
directions of their own and should be
allowed to do that
the idea that we should just tend to our
own nation we have deep troubles at home
and rather than tell the rest of the
world we have a great example to sell
you
you have to be like us these are larger
questions that are very difficult for
americans to grasp
americans don't like to understand
things
we like to do things
and that is what is propelling a foreign
policy of intervention and activism
the idea that we should do less in the
world
just doesn't get any traction in
washington there's
there's no payoff in that idea it's
always want to do more
you want to sanction that country no i
want to sanction them even more
you want to give military aid to that
government i want to give them even more
there's no payoff there's no percentage
in washington
for saying you know why don't we just
leave those parts of the world to deal
with their own problems
and help them diplomatically but not
insist on coercive
power let's try to do a little less in
the world and a little more at home
instead of trying to build the perfect
society in afghanistan how about
trying to work on one at home this
seems to suggest that there's
some limit on what the united states
can do in the world and that contradicts
something that's very deep in our
national character
right
you